well I talked about this it seems like
incessantly I feel like I do because
it's just becoming a real thing I'm
noticing even more and more in the
marketplace and that is we are raising a
generation that is digitally stupid if
you don't realize that what you say on
the internet cannot eventually be traced
back to you you're a fool and the
pictures that you post on the internet
are there for ever forever and when you
say something on Twitter every one can
see it when you say something on
Facebook every one can see it you this
you know Twitter is is like the old
fashioned country party line in the old
days when the phone systems were first
put in out in the country the everybody
not everybody but most people shared a
line and so while you were talking to
your friend your neighborhood that could
actually pick up and listen in if you
remember the old the old sitcom Green
Acres from a thousand years ago there
was a lot of episodes with that in it
that's what Twitter is and you know as
savvy as you would think that these
youngsters are they've grown up with
these technologies at their fingertips
and they are making huge mistakes
seniors graduating from college this
month and next month are finding out
that the topless Spring Break pictures
they posted are showing up in their
interview when they're trying to get a
job uh-huh people check your Facebook
page they want to see who you well
purport to be I was going to say who you
really are and the number of people who
no longer have the ability to do
conflict that have what we call digital
courage meaning they don't have the
backbone to face someone and say
something so they
resort to anonymous behind an icon hate
going out to their friends teenagers
doing this to each other
in a lot of you posting behind icons
comments on articles and negative things
about public figures or building hate
sites but you don't have the courage to
say it's you you're just a coward you're
just a straight-up coward
you're not making social commentary
about anything except you that's the
only social commentary you're making and
this comes out this week from CNN this
is what got me started on it the former
head of a private preparatory school in
Miami Florida is out an $80,000
discrimination settlement after his
daughter boasted about it on Facebook
Patrick's nay 69 the former head of
Gulliver preparatory school filed an age
discrimination complaint when his
2010-11 contract wasn't renewed the
school and snake came to an agreement in
which snake would be paid ten thousand
dollars in back pay and an eighty
thousand dollar settlement government
Gulliver schools also agreed to cut snez
attorneys a check for sixty thousand
dollars so one hundred and fifty
thousand dollars but before the ink
could dry on the deal stays daughter
took to Facebook boasting mama and Papas
nay won the case against Gulliver
Gulliver is now officially paying from
my vacation to Europe this summer Sukkot
snez daughter blasted the message or
1200 Facebook followers saw it which
included many current and former
Gulliver students word of the post
spread like wildfire back to school
officials within a few days Gulliver
school sent a letter to sneeze attorneys
stating the snake had broken a
confidentiality agreement that said he
would not and we'd not be receiving the
eighty thousand dollar settlement the
agreement stated that neither snow nor
his wife could speak about the
settlement to anyone except for his
attorneys and other professional
advisors which of course does not
include his daughter and does not
include twelve hundred of her facebook
followers
$80,000 now to start with I'm just
really glad that this little girls not
gonna get to go to Europe it just gives
me great joy and I'm really glad because
I mean you know it's her dad's fault too
because he raised this little monster I
mean my kids are not perfect they think
they could terror they could raise Cain
I'll just tell you they they know how
but I kind of tell you man to post
something like that on a social media
site aha forget if it actually had
anything to do with the legal settlement
or not and in violation of that this is
just a kid that this is the stuff kids
put on the websites this is how they
talk this is the kind of thing they do
now that that little fart wouldn't ever
in a million years sit in a meeting with
a group of adults she was talking about
and look at them and say that she does
not have that kind of courage in this
digital courage hiding behind things in
her case she won't even smart enough to
hide behind an icon she actually posted
her real name but man this stuff comes
back it comes back the opposite of this
is gratitude teaching your kids
gratitude and teaching them courage and
teaching them you know I heard my
next-door neighbor when I was growing up
we had a neighborhood where all the
parents were apt to parent you if you
didn't behave you could get busted in
anybody's house is what I'm saying
in our neighborhood and I my next-door
neighbor I've heard him say it a
thousand times
if you having anything nice to say don't
say anything at all but
when people have the ability to hide
behind electronics and do this kind of
thing then it they're they're cowards
and you're raising a coward when you
teach them this the opposite of that is
to raise them to have gratitude
gratitude starts with something as
simple as manners please thank you how
many children do you run into today they
say please and thank you
and smile open the door for someone
since that's basic gratitude and when
you start with that you have a higher
propensity to raise a child that will
not cost you $80,000 with her Facebook
post and you have a higher propensity to
not raise a child that will become a
spineless internet troll
hiding behind icons because they're not
man enough or woman enough to stand up
for what they really say are say as they
spend all their time being bitter and
anonymous this is the Dave Ramsey show
you